when historians look back at our time
they will not divide us into red and
blue and Republican Democrat they're
like the things that were wrong with
this were wrong with both sides in
different ways I do think they manifest
in a more dangerous way on the right but
on the left there is a rot
and it comes from Academia and I agree
and it filters down am I am I wrong
about that that's where it's all coming
from I just think this is an epitome of
it it's quite true the place in American
society really all Western Society where
the the horrific ideas of leftism and
wokism and collectivism socialism these
top-down ideas these ideas that are
anti-human Liberty they're anti the
individual because they don't want you
thinking for yourself they want to think
for you these have all taken root at
universities uh throughout this country
and as I said throughout the world they
will scream till their heads explode
about diversity but of course as you
guys know the one diversity that they
hate is diversity of thought